[Music]
on this wednesday night canadians
feeling deflated by rising inflation
how food prices are taking a bigger bite
than i make do with the best i can and
struggling businesses can't catch a
break
uncertainty and anxiety
nearly a thousand ukrainian troops at
the mercy of moscow
leadership review alberta premier jason
kenney learns his fate
and tracing the history of one illegal
gun used in two ontario murders
ballistics are much like fire prince
global news investigates how weapons are
smuggled into canada
and the battle of alberta my heart's
with the flames but my head is with the
oilers the stage is set for one of the
most heated rivalries in hockey
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
here it is in black and white what
canadians especially those on lower
fixed incomes already know pretty well
everything in canada costs more
inflation was up 6.8 percent in april a
31-year high
good evening and thanks for joining us
it's clear your dollar doesn't go as far
today as it once did the reasons are
complex and other countries are dealing
with high inflation too because we exist
in a global economy multiple factors
including russia's war in ukraine are
driving up the cost of the things we buy
and canadians are feeling the pinch eric
sorensen has our top story tonight
[Music]
steve mccauley was laid low by kovid and
so was his barbecue catering business
and just when things were looking up
inflation has hit like a ton of bricks
historically 80 or 90 percent of my
inquiries turned into bookings this year
it's less than fifty percent his quotes
have to reflect his costs more for gas
for equipment rising wages for staff and
of course the food he needs to cater the
cost of meat
has just gone through the roof right i
don't know 20 or 30 percent increase
it's the one expense no one can escape
the cost of food grocery prices are up
9.7 percent over a year ago
basics like fresh vegetables fresh fruit
meats are all up close to 10 percent
nearly everything at the grocery store
is costing a lot more frills or no
frills the financial squeeze is being
felt everything is going up it's very
very
stressful because we drive kids we used
to spend about 150 a week and now we
spend 250 a week wow yeah what's
happened first the post-pandemic
recovery gave prices a jolt supply
shortages added to that now the war in
ukraine a country that is a global
provider in energy and food has caused
prices to soar the bank of canada's two
percent target inflation rate remained
relatively within reach for years until
2022
inflation is now more than triple that
target rate
economists expect the bank of canada to
raise interest rates further to cool
inflation but for many that will mean
higher mortgage costs it is a double
whammy this financial expert's advice
tighten your budget till interest rates
can cool things down over the next few
months when bank of canada
increased their interest rate and i feel
the will by the end of summer
i i feel now until then it's
going to be really tough i shop at no
frills and i
make do with the best i can for now
canadians like aaron church are already
adjusting things that are on sale a lot
more
um
like no-name brands kind of like that
but
other than that just absorbing the cost
there's not much you can do steve
mccauley is absorbing costs and hoping
summer barbecue season can make the
difference it is very much a question
mark i'm i you know you'd have to ask me
come september
in the end how it all worked out how it
works out for the economy and for his
business eric sorensen global news
toronto
finland and sweden have officially
applied for membership in nato though
turkey is resisting it in ukraine
president vladimir zelinsky has proposed
extending martial law in the country for
another 90 days and if approved it would
be the third extension issued since
russia's invasion on february 24th
as the war drags on the fate of
prisoners of war taken by both russia
and ukraine hangs in the balance redmond
shannon reports
russia calls them nazis ukraine calls
them heroes by any name these soldiers
are now prisoners of war the kremlin
says almost 700 more ukrainian troops
left the azov style steel plant
wednesday some only barely walking
hobbling or carried out on stretchers
video from russia's defense ministry
claims to show injured soldiers being
held 40 kilometers east of mariupol
they gave me first aid and food i can't
complain says this man we don't know if
he was speaking under duress russia
isn't saying what will happen to them
next and has not agreed to ukraine's
wishes for a prisoner swap
the status of one of the russian troops
being held by ukraine is clear
vadim
pleaded guilty to murdering a ukrainian
civilian in the first war crimes trial
of the conflict
he allegedly shot a 62 year old on a
bicycle from a stolen car the dead man's
widow watching in court
meanwhile nato ambassadors from finland
and sweden formally submitted
applications to join the alliance the
security interests of all allies have to
be taken into account
and we are determined to work through
all issues for all issues read turkey's
issue
president erdogan again threatening to
block the nordic nations unless they
stop harboring kurdish separatists we
have also
legitimate security concerns that they
have been supporting
terrorist organizations u.s president
joe biden says he thinks a deal will be
hammered out i'm not going to turkey but
i think we're going to be okay biden has
also suggested the u.s will follow the
uk in guaranteeing the security of
finland and sweden while their
applications are being considered
redmond shannon global news london
russia is shutting down the cbc's news
bureau in moscow and revoking the
accreditation and visas of its
journalists the kremlin says it's
retaliation for canada's ban of the
russian state-controlled network rt a
russian foreign ministry spokesperson
said with regret we continue to note
outright attacks on the russian media
from countries of the so-called
collective west in march cbc suspended
reporting from inside russia because of
a new law which makes it illegal to call
the invasion of war and to report on
anything that's contrary to the official
kremlin line
this is one part of what prince charles
and his wife camilla saw in ottawa today
the rcmp musical ride the royal family
especially the queen have a
long-standing connection to the rcmp
during her 70-year reign the rcmp has
given the queen eight horses including
burmese which she rode for years
abigail beeman has more on the prince of
wales and duchess of cornwall's
jam-packed day in the nation's capital
these montreal high school students were
on a day trip to ottawa never expecting
to run into royalty i was like in shock
so i didn't like
it was in the moment but taina got it on
tape so we're gonna replay it over and
over yeah it's a pretty special day um i
wasn't expecting this at all a special
day for many royal fans with hundreds
showing up at the two events open to the
public lucky but also it was a little
bit surreal because yesterday i was
still watching like the crown the prince
of wales and duchess of cornwall toured
ottawa's byward market meeting both fans
and vendors they're peaceful and they go
and they they're fundraisers you know
they're and they're part of our identity
another meet and greet after laying a
wreath and flowers at the war memorial
we had a moment of like connection and
smile charles says
oh you've got the teddy bear paige
renolfson wasn't just excited to meet
charles and camilla
that serious shriek was for governor
general mary simon because i was so
happy to see her because i just love her
of course most of the royals encounters
wednesday were not by chance they met
with a number of ukrainian canadians at
this church the duchess tried her hand
at painting eggs and shaping pierogies
father tarrasquinash arrived from the
kiev region just last month when we feel
this support we are very grateful we
have feeling that
victory as close
as possible with
this kind of
friends stop it we have fun here go away
with waning support for the monarchy in
canada not everyone who followed along
was a fan
private property detective okay just
bjorn
the final event wednesday is the
platinum jubilee reception here at
rideau hall marking the queen's 70 years
on the throne invited guests include
indigenous leaders military members
politicians and a variety of canadians
focused on serving their communities the
final leg of the royal tour is thursday
when their royal highnesses visit the
northwest territories donna abigail
beamon at rideau hall tonight thanks
a first nation in eastern alberta is
piecing together its past after
discovering unmarked graves near the
site of a former residential school
saddle lake cree nation unearthed what
they believe are the partial remains of
several children who attended blue
quills indian residential school it's
feared there could be many more kim
smith's reports and a warning some of
the details are disturbing
for myself i was shocked looking back
eric large says he simply didn't know
what to do large is a residential school
survivor in 2017 he was doing work
excavating new grave sites at his
community cemetery when he uncovered
unexpected human remains i came across
some small bones i couldn't tell what
they were
i mean from what parts of the body for
almost 20 years since around 2004
members of the satellite crenation
northeast of edmonton have been making
similar discoveries community members
say they are believed to be children
found near the former blue quills
residential school site it can be safely
stated that in our community of twelve
thousand people
each family has had four to five
children who went missing from this
institution try finding a way to block
it out of my mind
saddle lake council member jason whiskey
jack says he's also accidentally found
remains over the years none of the
graves had markings of any sort
such as cross or headstones
all of this the skeleton remains were
the size of young children last year the
satellite crenation formed an indigenous
led society to investigate the possible
burial sites and mass graves catholic
church records obtained by the group
showed 212 children died at the school
which operated until 1931. a lot of us
have family members that we didn't even
know died in this institution and our
families never told us the first nation
is now asking community members to come
forward to do family tree mapping hoping
to identify the children it's also
hoping for funding support of ground
penetrating radar i don't think there's
any need for us to be hitting anymore
the pain caused by a dark chapter of
canada's past now being confronted by
another community
kim smith global news edmonton
there is support available for survivors
of residential schools and their
families the number is toll free it's
available 24 hours a day 1-800-721-0
the future of alberta's premiere hangs
in the balance coming up the leadership
review ballots are being counted
[Music]
it is a big night in alberta premier
jason kenney is stepping down as leader
of the united conservative party after
winning just 51.4 percent of the votes
in a leadership review a result he
admitted tonight he is disappointed with
global's tom vernon is with me from
calgary tom technically kenny won enough
to stay on but almost half the party
members also wanted him gone so i guess
staying
was untenable
yeah i mean we knew the party it was
going to be a close vote but this was
essentially a 50 50 split 51.4 to 48.6
now we'd heard a lot of discontent with
the premier's leadership over the last
18 months or so first from the
grassroots and then from a number of
caucus members and premier kenny told
supporters in the room that look
i was expecting more than this and it is
not enough to carry on as leader there
was the sound of shock and
disappointment from his supporters in
the room uh because of this obviously
premier jason kenny knew facing caucus
during a meeting tomorrow with only 50
percent of support in the party would
meant would have meant a tough
conversation with members like brian
jean and others who have said it's time
for you to go and to find a new leader
for this party he's obviously
languishing in the polls here with his
popularity rating and the party itself
is behind the opposition ndp as well so
it launches a leadership contest here in
alberta for the ucp ahead of an election
one year one year away
kenny seemed to me
almost relieved in his remarks that he
made after this result was announced
what did you think of the tone of his
remarks tonight and
and i guess we're looking at an election
one year from now right now the ndp
leading in the polls
yeah it was interesting we were standing
out here waiting to do another live hit
we saw the premier's vehicle pull in and
when he got out you can sense that there
wasn't a lot of excitement there's some
disappointed faces so i had the feeling
that oh you know maybe the vote didn't
go his way so when he made that
announcement and when you say relief
he's been under an intense amount of
pressure from inside his own party from
the members of alberta the polling
numbers that are below the ndp
fundraising numbers for the last year
that have been below the ndp as well so
it's a lot of pressure on him
not surprisingly decided what he did
with the amount of support it'll be
interesting to see how this leadership
race goes and who brings their name
forward to try and rebuild this party
ahead of next election
lots of change coming in alberta tom
thanks
ahead following the trail of an illegal
gun used in two ontario murders
[Music]
gun violence is on the rise in canada
homicides involving a firearm were up 91
between 2013 and 2020. last year there
were 277 fatal shootings and a handgun
was associated with nearly half of them
tonight tracy tong has part one of a
global news investigation following the
path of one handgun used in two ontario
murders we came into possession of this
gun
in 2017. this handgun has been in a
police evidence locker for more than
five years it's a taurus pt 740 slim a
subcompact semi-automatic pistol that
fires a 40-caliber cartridge
small in size but its consequences
immense and irreversible it's been a
hard week for friends and family coming
to terms with what happened
on june 14 2015 in london ontario
eighteen-year-old jeremy cook was shot
dead while trying to retrieve a cell
phone he had left behind in a taxi using
an app he tracked it to a tim horton's
parking lot where police say he found
three men in a car an altercation ensued
the men started to drive away and police
say when jeremy tried to hold on to the
car one of the men inside shot him
i just i couldn't believe it like it
still just seemed like
things don't happen you know like jeremy
was a good kid so was lee sent ross she
was just 14 years old when she was
killed in a toronto community housing
complex a month later she died
it happened in a friend's home a 13 year
old boy pulled the trigger in an
accidental discharge
a 40 caliber semi-automatic handgun was
retrieved by police people knew about
this gun didn't just show up
it came from somewhere
and now we know where ballistics testing
on the gun recovered where lee sent ross
was killed matched shell casings found
at jeremy cook's murder scene ballistics
are much like fire prince when a round
leaves a gun
the barrel leaves very distinctive
markings on it one single gun used in
two unrelated murders
a trace done by the bureau of alcohol
tobacco firearms and explosives also
known as the atf reveals it was
purchased in michigan by a man named
jermaine michael welsh u.s court
documents obtained by global news say
welsh's actions resulted in 33 guns
being put out on the street they
describe how welsh a canadian citizen
along with several co-defendants
purchased more than a hundred guns over
a period of five months
among those recovered in canada was a
firearm involved in a shootout with
police during a homicide investigation
and the gun that killed jeremy cook and
lee sent ross
according to the atf report that gun was
purchased from a licensed dealer
385 days before it was taken off the
streets that person
is responsible for those two deaths just
like the person who pulled the trigger
as far as i'm concerned because they
purchased that firearm knowing that they
were
giving it to someone who was going to
smuggle it across the border
well here is where it all started in
taylor michigan about 20 minutes outside
of detroit we now know that the taurus
pt 740 slim was purchased on june 20th
2014 at a gun show at the gibraltar
trade center that building has since
been demolished
but in a country where citizens have the
right to keep and bear arms you don't
have to look far
there are gun shows every weekend in
michigan
and about 4 000 licensed firearms
dealers scattered throughout the state
and getting your hands on a gun even as
a canadian
isn't that hard if you're willing to lie
tracy tong global news
it's known as lying and buying tomorrow
in part two tracy explains how easily
guns end up in canada and you can read
more about the story online at
globalnews.ca
global national oilers versus flames
next a playoff matchup fueling the fire
between fans
the u.s women's national soccer team has
finally received what it was entitled to
an equal share of world cup prize money
the u.s women's team world cup champions
have struck a deal with the u.s soccer
federation to eliminate a long-standing
pay gap that means prize money for
playing in a fifa world cup will be
pooled and divided equally among the
men's and women's teams seoul follows a
gender discrimination lawsuit which was
settled in february for 24 million the
men earned much larger bonuses for
qualifying for the world cup even though
they never won the tournament the
women's national team has won four times
another battle is brewing this one's
three decades in the making the calgary
flames and the edmonton oilers are set
to reignite one of the most fierce nhl
rivalries it is the second round of the
playoffs and blake law is in calgary for
game one of this showdown blake
the first clash of this battle of
alberta takes place here at the saddle
dome but even before the first puck has
been dropped the war of words is already
well underway i'm thinking about renting
an airbnb for myself i might move out
the greenways live in calgary but flames
fan jessica is outnumbered separate
meals separate tables
no no camaraderie there whatsoever
speaking of division red deer sits
almost exactly halfway between the
cities good luck choosing sides there
you ask anybody in red deer today you'll
probably get a 50 50 split it's that
close my heart's with the flames but my
head is with the oilers
both cities are getting creative using
the rivalry for good in edmonton oilers
fans can make a small donation to a
local charity and show the flames how
they really feel want to do something
fun around the battle of alberta and
celebrate how much we hate calgary and
even flames coach daryl sutter is
letting his excitement show they might
cheer for the oilers might cheer for the
flames big deal right it's a sport
that's what it's about
like the best thing ever the nhl what
more could he ask for calgary's head
coach went on to say as intense as this
series will be it will bring people
together after a few years of an oil
crash drought in the fields and of
course the pandemic he says that's
something all albertans can look forward
to
no matter the outcome
donna that's for sure blake law in
calgary thank you and that is global
national for this wednesday i'm donna
friesen tonight's your canada is jasper
alberta closer to edmonton than calgary
i know but don't read anything into that
thanks for watching have a good night
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you